ok whyatt Against the Dark Passenger
International Master she doesn't have a
name in down so don't know how that is
alright so the NIMS own so I'll go for
the samish line always good for for an
interesting game if you lose your fair
share of games as white certainly it is
not really am a great opening but then
it leads to interesting play this is no
question so he M appreciates appreciate
so this Bishop g5 pins I'm trying to
save tempe here by pushing all the porns
instantly yeah I interesting so hmm how
to play this now ok let's do this first
I don't think that taking only for is so
great for black
would be surprised if this would be it
would be it would be really good can
it's possible what I would would be
would be quite quite strange takes
Bishop takes d5 assess some somewhat
weird okay but I need to react now and
the question is how exactly but take on
f5 now I probably just recaptures an md5
he's got 96 this kind of setup and I
don't know if if I found like that gem 5
done not sure the not sure okay I go if
I it's it's very closed if this is this
position here in the center damn aha
well this is interesting now I can go d5
and I like to do that of course this
sound now leads to an interesting
structure I've got this pulse now d 65 f
4 and have a look at the night only
eight this is a typical maneuver in the
sameish on ya block em back and take the
phone I don't mind this is a typical on
position in the sameish wear white has
managed to push all the porns here and
what black as some is facing here is
playing with a piece down the night only
eight is not playing and this is the
problem he has a big big issue with the
snide he can play g6 and night to night
to h5 but this is really the only plan
yeah I had this already a couple of
times blacken the kind of structure I
mean not the exact position like and try
to play on the queenside but there's not
so much happening I don't even mind to
exchange Queens this is Sir
quite funny in this position simply
because he's playing without the night
so on still let's see how to how to
continue should I even try to to force
the Queen exchange I'll try that going
to be five so we prevented that okay
then let's go go to f3 now with the the
spawn move um the b6 some poor nesa is
weakened also so i really i can just
exchange queens iam
it all depends on on the fact that this
night is a dead piece if he can get it
into play then like it says perfectly
all right if not then it's very
interesting for white one problem is
that he can we can even maybe play a
five and close the Queen sat down
completely the other idea that black
asses to play at some point g5 not it
seems that he tries to do that yeah this
I thought I'm that I have on the move a
five maybe I'm over playing my hand here
this is possible it's just a blitz them
stuff like night h5 ng5 might break up
the kingside i would like more temperate
I don't didn't have the time at any
point in this game and now the problem
is how does he keep the queenside right
to take here and okay so he's actually
okay okay let's let's let's do this
first don't don't mind that keep a for
protected so sunny end game with the
porn down but how do you get the night
into play this is an interesting
question
Knight c3 was my idea to activate might
be four to be six mile but was was my
plan but he tries to play King g4 and
night h5m I should have that King f3
problem yeah probably this was aa I
should have played King f3 now I'm i
cannot i cannot protect this ok it's not
let's maybe still there still are ideas
here but King g3 will flame and then c6
maybe this is still still viable but I
could have played much better with king
of three and then I'm not really sure
what what what the assessment of this
position is yeah yeah I am
yeah there's nothing can resign yeah I
spoil this with this this this this was
too quick this was just I played this
too quickly yeah I'm not one hundred
percent sure but I think this is this
must be good for wide here king of three
and and I think it's gone for him light
isn't actually not a form computer gifts
this is winning yeah and it must be good
for for provide to look at this this
crap piece on g7 but I thought really
king of free would be better and then he
says he just returns and why it doesn't
have a way to proceed to him maybe it
looks terrible with the with the this
destroyed and he says actually that my
move wins ok Knight b6 night here and
what now Knight d4 without a true nano
it's now it's a strong interesting and
now wide winds okay yeah Bishop see
three wins now interesting why why why
does it win a night f4 bishop you one
check of course a tree was was a really
good trick actually which I didn't
really like it didn't really didn't
realize and bishops III now is just
winning out of course he cannot go here
this just wins once the winds the night
and he doesn't have a move black black
is just busted can move here and then
this and he's completely helpless
against 97 it's just gone ah this would
have been a really nice finish to this
game a shame this would really be the
kind of way to tour to him yet to win
after you played against this night the
whole time notice and this is actually
very interesting endgame the only
counter place is what what he tried but
I'm also very much interested in ok 9
a-4 then due to technical reasons is
good but that this should be should be a
draw according to the computers still a
bit difficult for me to accept
yeah it mean it's possible I'm not
saying that this is a completely
outlandish that this is this might be a
draw let's say here and he's just
staying up and go here yeah he protects
the d7 lab porn with the king
it's really hard to believe all this
maybe maybe it is the thing is he's
really playing without this piece and
okay what this piece is doing it attacks
the pawn of course but I can protect it
for instance with Bishop e3 at some
stage let's not grab grab just just to
show the idea if I if I protect it with
the bishop move at some point it's just
a piece down does this Bishop is doing
more than just protecting the porn it's
just it's also covering lots of
important squares and now I've got this
or this move coming with play against
the pawns get this actually and now the
computer gives a wider an advantage it
must be better for what no no question I
mean the pawn down is not not the bigger
the big issue yeah very interesting game
unfortunately I didn't manage to really
am to play a precise iam to do to win it
but very interesting yeah I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching